do you think kovad do you think the sun
can pull covert out of your [ __ ] you
know do you remember when he said that
yes and so i was like what is it like
being that guy going home that night to
his wife and like that was the first
time trump talked to him so i just did
this whole long act out of her being
like how was your day dave how was your
day and he was like
you always do that you always downplay
your successes how was it how was it huh
you worked really hard to get this job
uh well the the president talked to me
that's what i'm talking about dave mr
president's new best friend you always
do that you always don't share with me
your successes what did he say uh well
he asked if the sun could suck uh if the
sun could suck your d if you could the
sun could suck if you could come cover
it out of your uh your peanut if the sun
would blow you and you would and you
could suck the cover out of your dick if
you would if you get a sun suck if
mother nature would blow and you could
just come covered out of your out of
your penis is what he asked me
and he asked you that
it's just a big long so i like those big
long actors but that's a that's so snl
that have they got many little sketches
yeah so you haven't had your agent like
send you because i made a few tapes and
they probably
and i would always and you know dana a
car was a good buddy of mine and i would
always send him stuff and he he'd as
polite as he could be supportive without
not wanting to tell me too much because
he just was like i don't want to
you know almost like the way when a
young comic asks you for advice and
you're like i don't want to tell you too
much one way or the other because i want
to shape what's going on so he kind of
give a few little technical things but
uh i don't know also every year who
knows what they were truly looking for i
think one year when i really when i sent
a tape that i really uh liked um
they uh
they just took a couple gals and then
the kid was at bonyang the uh the asian
kid yeah um
but yeah i've heard these nightmare and
great stories from people that we've had
on but about the showcases not only in
the clubs but where you go actually to
rockefeller center and there's five
people sitting in the audience lauren
and we have no laughter yeah and they
bring you out on the stage of you know
we're on on fallon stage or maybe even
the snow stage and do that but
i would think too that you know from
having the stand-up and the don't know
theater back that i wouldn't be as
nervous of being on stage like that but
maybe so i mean that those seem like
insane just stakes and like i i'm sure
no one is immune to getting there
finally whether how big the dream was
where you don't get overtaken by the
moment right like and you're just like
looking around and i would try to
probably not
i don't know well maybe
how are you like pre-show do you like to
or before i could talk show appearance
do you like to mix it up and like
converse does it kind of like help to to
bleed into uh what you're about to do my
big thing is just and this wouldn't
apply to the uh well it would i want to
listen to what's happening prior to when
i do yeah so um i'm okay with i have no
preparation like i don't prepare for
anything i didn't prepare for this
podcast but uh it feels like you did it
feels like you know
i know you i'm i'm a fan so i know you
but there's no preparation nothing you
knew about dirt day prior you acted
surprised for that that's actually
you've been a big that's acting i'd
rather do it here on the podcast than
the movie his last name's prior
no you said oh dirty dirty
dirty oh my god there's the twist yeah
he's related somehow oh my god
so um but what i was saying was um
i do on a talk show want to hear
everything that they've
everything that's happened to me
so that if i want to do a call back or i
want to reference i love that yes so
even if i was at a an audition for um
snl i would probably want access to wow
to a screen and see what somebody does
before me and then in that moment where
i totally go blank
and and i know that the guy before me
had a a little bit of rough time i go
but this is like you did the impression
of kyle i will do the impression this is
not what you think i know you didn't
like it but isn't this exactly like the
guy before and kind of
be able to be in the moment yeah that's
not that doesn't have to do with nerves
that's just you that is your form of
preparation so you know what to say or
do that's not like preparing
i can't walk out in just not knowing
where i am but
nervousness is my fuel yeah i love fear
it's good to feel
a little uh not fully comfortable right
i've never been comfortable i don't know
what that's like it makes you raise your
game i always somebody asked me that
like are you getting nervous and i was
like i always allow for
yeah like and that's that's also why i
love doing um
you know breaking the fourth wall and
doing crowd stuff because it's like
there's so much uncertainty there yeah
um and that uh it's to me i my analogy
has always been like i like roller
coasters and still do you do oh
terrified but that's am i but i love
that
so like if you like roller coasters you
don't want to go on a roller coaster
that goes you know 30 miles an hour in a
straight line through the trees right
you know that's boring but if if you
think you've come really close to death
and you've been tossed way up in the air
and then you're adrenaline and you're
you're almost at the verge of tears you
go i want to get on again it's like
adrenaline i love the adrenaline of
just and also because i suffer from so
many mental health issues sure that
awkwardness and fear are a great
distraction from whatever other mental
pain i could be do you uh seek out
awkward moments like do you enjoy
showing up for me is an awkward moment
your tick tocks are so great by the way
i just had it thank you quick vision of
you the just the uh the side-by-side
things you comment on or react to thank
you um and it makes me think like
how great you'd be with something like
that in real life like seeing but that's
why i like hosting yeah you know hosting
a game show i'm doing [ __ ] right now
on netflix what was fun about it is
like just being able to call i don't
know what they're gonna say i don't even
know if they know what the [ __ ] they're
talking about but i was actually playing
along and doing it and that's like my
milieu i love that not knowing not
it's the opposite of being a regular
game show host where they just hand you
the cards and you read the questions and
then you go now we're going into round
two you got that one correct and yeah
that i couldn't do in game play right
you could never do that you always have
no needed to have uh
it be something where you can loose yeah
yeah and read the room and it seems like
you have that i think so yeah yeah i get
that from you
[Music]